I'm legally required by talkshow rules
to ask you if we will see the Hulk again
I do know that I did give Kevin Feige
the blockbuster award at the Hollywood
Film Awards the other day mmm - a
smattering of applause and and he did
say hey do you think there's any more
story left here and I said I could
probably come up with a few story lines
and he said well maybe you should come
in and we'll have a talk
you heard it here the epic forces of
darkness and light that have come in to
claim
again that's irrigated welcome back
everyone it's Charlie so this is gonna
be my New Avengers 5 hope video there's
also a bunch of new Marvel movies during
Marvel phase 5 they just announced that
I'll breakdown and there's a bunch of
deleted scenes of the Hulk from The
Avengers infinity saga box said we're
still doing that giveaway for that - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave the Marvel phase 4
movie that you're most excited about on
the video I'll start with the Hulk stuff
that Mark Ruffalo is talking about then
talk about the Marvel phase 5 movies
then talk about the new deleted scenes
that they just released of the Hulk just
going down the list top 5 style number 5
Mark Ruffalo has a couple Hulk
storylines he's pitching Kevin Feige
because as he said Kevin Feige really
wants the Hulk to come back during
Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5 the funny
thing about that is that as most of you
have probably realized Mark Ruffalo
still has a contract with Marvel and
Kevin Feige can force him to come back
he doesn't need to ask his permission to
bring Mark Ruffalo back he can just say
we're using you in this movie show up or
we'll sue you issues the Kevin Feige is
nice like that and he wants to get the
actors input for their characters
especially when it's gonna be the ninth
or tenth times that Mark Ruffalo has
portrayed that character in an MCU
project when you include all the
post-credits scenes that he's appeared
in if you've been following the MCU
actors since avengers end game came out
talking about the futures of their
characters at least the ones that are
still technically alive Mark Ruffalo has
already said what his vision for future
hulk is in the MCU in since they've
gotten so good with motion capture
technology he can actually keep playing
that character for forever if he wants
to but the big thing that he said he
wanted to do next was to be more of a
professor Hulk mentor to the newer
younger characters coming up literal and
metaphorical professor Hulk so he's
talking about the Young Avengers but
that's not all of it so number four
young Avengers Hulk
since Marvel announced that they were
working on eventually doing a young
avengers project i've done a couple
videos about it everyone's just been
wondering which characters they put on
that team because of all those new
disney plus series that they announced
we already have most of the original
Young Avengers comic book roster there's
cape bishop hawkeye debuting Cassie Lang
from Avengers and game is stature Kamala
Khan miss Marvel not debuting for a
while but she'll be around pretty soon
the adult version of Monica Rambeau
debuting during the one division series
remember she was a little girl during
the Captain Marvel movie they recast her
as an adult for the Scarlet Witch
envisioned TV show it if rumors are to
be believed Wiccan and speed who were
supposedly going to be introduced in
some form during the wand division
series as the children of Scarlet Witch
maybe Tom Hollands spider-man
maybe Cherie because both of them are
still super young and then of course the
she-hulk character Jennifer Walters
that's debuting a little bit later
during Marvel phase 5 but looking at the
schedule here they can't actually do an
actual Young Avengers project until they
introduce all these characters which
going by everything that they've
announced so far wouldn't be till at
least around 2022 or 2023 even if they
don't have room in their theatrical
release schedule for a Young Avengers
movie a six hour Young Avengers movie
broken into six episodes on Disney Plus
would be just as good same amount of
money you just get way more story with
those characters young Avengers versus
came to conquer would be amazing
within that though Mark Ruffalo as he's
saying would just play a sort of mentor
role to them it also probably smashing
some things during a final big battle
you don't put the Hulk in a movie as the
Hulk without letting him smash some
stuff but number three the other big
project that the Hulk will be part of
during Marvel phase four much sooner
would be the she-hulk series if you
don't know what her origin story is
basic explainer Jennifer Walters starts
as a lawyer who also just happens to be
Bruce banners cousin she's prosecuting a
bunch of criminals they shoot her before
she can uncover what they're doing but
Bruce Banner just happens to be in the
area and because they have the same
blood type
she's quickly bleeding out he transfuse
'as his gamma-irradiated blood into her
to save her life
it totally works she's saved she wakes
up in a hospital bed but she's
surrounded by the criminals that
previously tried to kill her disguised
as doctors trying to finish her off
because her body's now been infused with
the Hulk's gamma she transforms into the
savage she-hulk for the first time
instantly healing all of her wounds
smashing through all the thugs beating a
confession out of them leading to a
successful conviction where she gets
them thrown in jail and she wins her
case the big difference between where
she starts out and where Bruce Banner
Hulk started out is that she's not quite
as powerful but she still has her mind
and she can still speak like professor
Hulk speaks really she starts out more
as a female version of professor
Hulk than a female version of regular
Hulk the mindless version of the Holt is
way more powerful for the most part she
spends her time as a criminal attorney
for instance if spider-man needed some
help and daredevil were not available
another good attorney in the MCU that
they're introducing would be Jennifer
Walters she-hulk
Mark Ruffalo would just participate in
that series to give her her origin story
and mentor her through the process of
what it means to be a Hulk
then she Hulk would cross over into the
movies but they haven't said which
movies she's going to be in aside for
him say like a Young Avengers project
number two though the five new Marvel
phase 5 movies that they just announced
everyone got really crazy about this a
couple days ago you probably saw the
news
so Marvel announced dates for five new
movies after Black Panther 2 this is
what the new schedule looks like after
that look at all these untitled movies
that's a lot of dates we know what some
of them are though so February 2022
right before Black Panther 2 is most
likely gonna be ant-man 3 they just said
that they were starting work on it right
now Michael Douglas accidentally let us
know that they were gonna start filming
it in early 2021 which means they'd be
done and ready to release it
February 2022 but here's where we get to
the really good stuff this is exciting
July right after Black Panther 2 is
rumoured that that will be Marvel's
Fantastic Four which kind of winds up
being a big black panther Easter Egg for
a classic black panther Fantastic Four
so if you haven't read those original
Fantastic Four comics the Black Panther
character debuted for the first time in
Fantastic Four number 52 in 1966 so
introducing Marvel's Fantastic Four for
the first time in a black panther to
post-credit scene would be a huge Easter
Egg for those original comics October
that year also exciting is rumored to be
Deadpool three Marvel is definitely
gonna make Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds has
been teasing that for Marvel phase 5
it's just unclear how they're going to
brand it and how they're going to
release it will they use Fox because
Marvel technically doesn't release rated
R films in Deadpool 3 is confirmed to be
rated R but number one all the 2023
Marvel movie is that next year so right
now based on when they said they're
starting production on guardians 3 that
February 2023 movie seems like it's
going to be guardians of the galaxy vol
Captain Marvel 2 was mentioned at Comic
Con that will probably take the mayor
state right after that they're both
space based franchises in Captain
Marvel's area of space that she police's
with the Korean the scrolls is right
next to where the guardians of the
galaxy typically operate
so maybe Captain Marvel post-credit
scene during guardians 3 we already know
that spider-man 3 was confirmed by Sony
and Marvel for July this year and then
the November movie is probably gonna
wind up being Marvel's new blade because
Kevin Feige announced at a Comic Con but
didn't give it a specific date other
than to say it would be Marvel phase 5
those will be all the movie titles but
the order of a couple of the later ones
might swish just a little bit between
now and when those come out because that
is a long ways off biggest surprise for
me is that we probably won't see
Avengers 5 until 2024 which I'm totally
fine with and of course the Hulk would
come back for Avengers 5 but I'm mostly
looking forward to right now is the new
Marvel version of Fantastic Four and
x-men what are those gonna look like who
are they going to recast as the major
characters once they do that then we can
start thinking about what the new
Avengers roster is going to look like so
moving on to those new deleted scenes
that they released of the Hulk from
infinity war in Avengers endgame there's
the alternate ending where he bursts out
of the Hulkbuster and does another one
with him in Black Widow finding him as
Professor Hulk on the battlefield where
she almost passes out from surprise the
Hulkbuster scene as cool as it sounds is
so unfinished in its current form that
it looks like ps2 graphics but it's
still cool to think about what that
might have been had they finished it and
put it in the actual movie The Black
Widow Hulk alternate ending is just
another really nice moment with the two
of them something that you didn't really
get at the end of Avengers end game when
she sacrificed herself for all of you
that were upset that they didn't include
any scenes to back up what he was saying
to Captain America I tried to bring her
back but the stones wouldn't let me you
have to imagine that he also went into
the soul world just like Iron Man and
Thanos did when they snapped the
gauntlets if there was anyone that he
would have seen and spoken to in that
soul world it would have been Black
Widow there's a bunch more bonus
features like this and deleted scenes on
the Avengers infinity saga box set so
there any that I think will make for an
interesting video I will totally make
videos about them some of them are
really cool but some of them just don't
work and you totally understand why they
got deleted I will keep that infinity
saga box set giveaway open until they
drop the Black Widow trailer
in a couple weeks everybody click here
for that New Avengers what-if trailer
video and click here for my brand-new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]